resuelve para x tenemos 8 que multiplica
a 3 x 10 es igual a 28 x menos 14 menos
4x como hemos hecho en todas las
ecuaciones hasta ahora queremos agrupar
las x de un solo lado pero antes de
hacer eso vamos a simplificar ambos
lados del lado izquierdo vamos a
multiplicar 3 x + 10 por 8
así es que básicamente vamos a
distribuir el 8 vamos a aplicar la
propiedad distributiva aquí esto nos
queda 8 x 3 x 24 x + 8 x 1080 que es
igual a y del lado derecho tenemos 28 x
menos 14 menos 4x vamos a combinar 28 x
y menos 4x esto es igual a 28 x 4 x 24 x
menos 14 y lo siguiente que hacemos pero
espera esta ecuación y es un tanto
sospechosa vamos a confirmar esto
restando 24 x a ambos lados de la
ecuación si hacemos eso van a
desaparecer las x pues aquí tenemos 24 x
del lado izquierdo y 24 x del lado
derecho al pasar
24 x del otro lado se eliminan veamos lo
restamos 24 x del lado derecho y 24 x
del lado izquierdo que nos queda del
lado izquierdo estos términos se
cancelen nos quedan 80 es igual del lado
derecho estos dos términos se cancelan y
nos queda tan solo menos 14 y esto es
realmente bizarro pues la ecuación ahora
estipula que 80 es igual a menos 14 pero
sabemos que eso no es verdad eso no
sucede 80 no es igual a menos 14 80 es
distinto de menos 14 así es que esta
ecuación en realidad no tiene solución
esto no tiene solución no tiene solución
no hay valor de x que haga 80 igual a
menos 14